one of the biggest news weekend's in a
long time Attorney General Jeff Sessions
has fired
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe just
days before he would have qualified for
a pension as a longtime government
employee the official reason given is
that an internal FBI office determined
that McCabe wasn't forthcoming during an
interview with the Justice Department's
inspector general that McCabe made an
unauthorized disclosure to the media and
that when speaking under oath McCabe
lacked candor Donald Trump the president
cheerleading the firing immediately
taking to Twitter and saying Andrew
McCabe fired a great day for the
hard-working men and women of the FBI a
great day for democracy sanctimonious
James Comey was his boss and made McCabe
look like a choirboy
he knew all about the lies and
corruption going on at the highest
levels of the FBI McCabe is not mincing
words he's being super clear about what
he thinks motivated this firing the
Russia investigation in a statement
saying they have every reason to believe
that I could end up being a significant
witness in whatever the Special Counsel
comes up with and so they are trying to
create this counter narrative that I am
NOT someone who can be believed or
trusted now even if you believe that
what Andrew McCabe did right lacking
candor in a public in testimony making
an unauthorized disclosure if you
believe that stuff is a problem and you
may the idea that this isn't political
is absurd right because Kellyanne Conway
has violated the Hatch Act at minimum
once or twice if not more no no
repercussions whatsoever they had a
serial wife beater who couldn't get a
security clearance working at the White
House for months in Rob Porter they
found out and they still didn't do
anything until the pressure from the
public became too great
they have cabinet secretaries out
spending inappropriately on private air
fare of first-class flights $30,000
dining table
but this is the guy that needs to be
fired days before qualifying for his
pension and it's not even the broader
administration hypocrisy right what
about the laughable specific double
standard of Jeff Sessions the Attorney
General firing anyone for lacking candor
it's totally comical after his string of
I don't remember anything ever but yet
still managing to lie and or forget
depending on who you believe about his
various meetings with Russian
individuals this is all meant as Andrew
McCabe is saying to paint the FBI a
broadly and specifically James Comey and
Andrew McCabe as not trustworthy and the
goal is to preemptively discredit Robert
Mulder's investigations sessions was
totally dishonest when he told senators
that he had no communications with
Russians and then his explanations for
why he didn't originally just tell the
truth about that are even more
ridiculous and Trump has had his eye on
getting rid of McCabe for a long time
remember when Trump asked McCabe during
that conversation some time ago who he
voted for when they met what this means
is that Robert Muller is getting very
close and the dominoes are going to
start falling and the picture is clearer
every day because I said you might
remember and I'm not patting myself on
the back for this many people said it
when Republicans on the House
Intelligence Committee put out a memo
saying we're done we're done
investigating there was no collusion
Democrats said wait hold on
we weren't even consulted about this
we're on the Intel committee we don't
think we're done
never mind the that that we've even
spoken to everybody we want to speak to
it was very clear that they were
starting to panic and now we're starting
to see why mccabe could have retired
yesterday sunday after more than twenty
years of working for the FBI
and now his pension is at risk there's
one bit of interesting news not to
divert too much from the main storyline
but on on the pension thing there's a
Democratic lawmaker who's offered to
hire McCabe for a few days to get his
time and service long enough to get that
full pension it's congressman mark Pocan
who tweeted Andrew called me I could
use a good 2-day report on the biggest
crime families in Washington DC and also
back on Twitter as a result of this
firing of Andrew McCabe is FBI director
James Comey who tweeted that he will
soon be talking saying quote mr.
president the American people will hear
my story very soon and they can judge
for themselves who is honorable and who
is not consider for a moment that all
three people that James Comey talked to
about his conversations with Donald
Trump as FBI director have been fired
Andrew McCabe being number three Comey
told his chief of staff James rebecky
about his conversations with Trump he
told the FBI general counsel James Baker
about his conversations with Trump and
he told Andrew McCabe the deputy FBI
director about his conversations with
Trump and all three have been fired this
is not normal I do not believe in
coincidences like this and you even have
a Republican senator yeah one that the
right loves to hate but a Republican
senator nonetheless Lindsey Graham says
it's gone too far and he wants the
Senate to hold hearings about this
firing he said yesterday on CNN State of
the Union I think we owe it to the
average American to have a hearing in
the Judiciary Committee where Attorney
General Jeff Sessions come forward with
whatever documentation he has about the
firing and give mr. mchabe the chance to
defend himself
I believe when it comes to this issue we
need as much transparency as possible to
make sure it wasn't politically
motivated beautiful statement I agree
with it completely but now we actually
have to make sure that it happens
because Lindsey Graham has called for
hearings before or at least has said
colloquially that something needs to be
looked into in a nonpartisan way or a
bipartisan way and it just doesn't
happen and we know that in the current
political climate that's easier said
than done so very very clear that this
was not a firing merely for the reasons
stated this is part of a bigger picture
to get in the way now I'm stopping short
of using the legal term obstruction of
justice because that's for someone else
to decide maybe Robert Mulder or someone
else but this is certainly
an attempt to get in the way of Robert
molars investigation and we'll see if
they get away with it the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership